bei der entwicklung des web antriebs
wurde fast unbemerkt ein entscheidender
fortschritt realisiert masse mit
negativer gravitation kommt jetzt also
der bob antrieb also der antrieb der uns
ermöglichen soll zwischen den sternen
systemen und galaxien mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit zu reisen es
wäre neben quantencomputern und
künstliche intelligenz der
wahrscheinlich größte fortschritt der
menschheit aber wie soll das gehen was
wurde jetzt also genau entwickelt clip
zum song the witcher mit dem mob antrieb
in der spektakulären edition zukunft
rowohlt hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende wissenschafts videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los gehen
herzlich willkommen in der edition
zukunft rowohlt beschäftigung mit den
spannendsten und spektakulärsten
entwicklung die laut der wissenschaft
tatsächlich möglich sind und zwar mit
themen aus meinem neuen buch per aufzug
in den weltraum erschienen im rowohlt
verlag und in diesem buch geht es um
unsere zukunft um realistische szenarien
wie sie aussehen könnte
wissenschaftlich begründet wer also
einen blick in die zukunft werfen möchte
der sollte hier auf den link zum buch
unterm klicken aber am ende habe ich
dazu noch mal eine ganz besondere bitte
die relativitätstheorie hat uns unsere
grenzen aufgezeigt und die lauten
zusammengefasst wir kommen hier nicht
weg das universum ist eigentlich für
jeden bewohner ein gefängnis es ist
unmöglich darin größeren distanzen zu
überwinden denn je schneller wir reisen
desto schwerer werden wir die zeit
vergeht außenrum schneller wodurch wir
in die zukunft reisen und es wird immer
mehr energie benötigt um auch nur ein
wenig zu beschleunigen und mit heutigen
antrieben würde es jahre dauern und die
benötigte treibstoffmenge wäre
unermesslich es gibt also zahlreiche
grenzen die unüberwindlich erscheinen
wir sehen es ja schon daran dass
entfernungen im weltall in lichtjahren
angegeben werden ein lichtjahr ist die
entfernung die ein lichtstrahl in einem
jahr zurücklegt und schneller als licht
können wir uns nicht im raum bewegen und
selbst die lichtgeschwindigkeit wäre
eben nur mit einem
nicht zu bewältigen den aufwand zu
erreichen science fiction autoren und
autorinnen haben aber eine lösung für
dieses problem gefunden den warp antrieb
schon 1948 schrieb chester es geyer in
seinem roman the flight to this darling
davon und wir alle kennen den warp
antrieb aus star trek von gene
roddenberry nicht selten liegen science
fiction autoren und autorinnen ja gar
nicht so falsch schulden werden hat die
mondlandung vorausgesehen und sein
u-boot nautilus war atomgetriebenen das
war damals schon verrückt und liegen
jetzt vielleicht dieses science fiction
autoren mit dem web antrieb richtig die
idee dahinter stammt aus der physik
durch die rotverschiebung von licht im
universum wissen wir dass sich das
universum ausdehnt und zwar der raum
selbst für den gilt das gesetz der
unabänderlichen lichtgeschwindigkeit
nämlich nicht licht aus entfernten
galaxien kommt bei uns rot verschoben
also mit einer niedrigeren wellenlänge
an es wurde quasi verlangsamt allerdings
ist das de facto nicht der fall
der raum in dem es sich bewegt hat sich
währenddessen viel mehr ausgedehnt raum
kann sich vollkommen unabhängig bewegen
und das auch schneller als das licht die
idee für den warp antrieb ist deshalb
simpel und genial dann verändern wir
doch einfach den raum und verkürzen die
strecke zwischen start und ziel wir
wollen ihn wir drücken ihnen zusammen
das ist die idee von warp antrieb das
raumschiff drückt den raum vorsicht
zusammen und den team hinter sich wieder
aus aber wie müsste ein solcher antrieb
gebaut sein dass wir ganz schnell an ein
paar hindernisse zum ersten mal hat der
mexikanische physiker megane coupe oh ja
das durchgerechnet allerdings war für
seinen antrieb so viel materie mit
negativer masse nötig dass es nicht so
praktikabel war zehn milliarden mal mehr
solcher materie war nötig als wir ganz
normale materie im universum haben
inzwischen wurde an alko bias
gleichungen einiges verbessert und der
bedarf konnte deutlich reduziert werden
der us forscher errechnete die benötigte
menge auf einige hundert kilogramm
aber wofür wird materie mit negativer
masse benötigt und was muss man sich
darunter vorstellen
die idee ist dabei dass materie mit
positiver und materie mit negativer
masse gegenseitig mit dem raum
interagieren und in wie erwähnt vor dem
raumschiff komprimieren und dahinter
wieder expandieren normale materie würde
dabei gravitation der zeuge und die
materie mit negativer masse anti
gravitation wir wissen ja aus der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie das
gravitation die raumzeit krümmt so weit
so gut es gibt nur einen klitzekleinen
materie mit negativer masse
die existiert nämlich nicht im universum
wie kann sie also erzeugt werden
tatsächlich ist das einem forschungsteam
bereits gelungen ist hat ein
bose-einstein-kondensat mit negativer
masse erzeugt das entsteht also dieses
kondensat wenn man atome eines gases
annähernd auf den absoluten nullpunkt
von minus 273 15 grad celsius
heruntergekühlt dann befinden sie sich
also die atome in einem extremen
entweder zustand sie bilden das
bose-einstein-kondensat kurz gk das
besondere daran ist diese atome
verhalten sich wie ein einziges atom und
dieser atomkomplex schwingt dann
wellenartig im gleichtakt man kann in
dieser atomwolke kein einzelnes atom
mehr ausmachen sie sind eins geworden
und jetzt hat das forschungsteam mit
diesem kondensat etwas sehr verrücktes
angestellt und damit negative masse die
in der quantenphysik theoretisch zwar
möglich war auch praktisch werden lassen
wichtiges vorwissen jedes teilchen hat
einen spin einen drehimpuls das ist je
nach teilchen unterschiedlich peter
engels unseren team an der washington
state university haben das
bose-einstein-kondensat ausprobieren
atomen erzeugt danach mit lasern
durchgeschüttelt und damit ihren spin
geändert das verblüffende ergebnis die
rubidium atome verhielten sich jetzt so
als hätten sie eine negative masse das
bose-einstein-kondensat befindet sich in
diesem experiment in einer
wenn sie geöffnet wird müsste sich
eigentlich aus brighton jetzt war aber
genau das gegenteil der fall wenn wir
sie schubsten beschleunigten sie
rückwärts so der co autor michael fox
die forschung ist damit dem bob antrieb
ein ganzes stück näher gekommen doch
trotzdem bleiben noch eine reihe
erheblicher probleme
das raumschiff wäre in der blase nicht
steuerbar das innere der blase könnte
sich beim reisen schneller als das licht
so stark aufheizen dass alles darin
verbrennt beim abbremsen könnte eine
solche schockwelle entstehen dass sie
alles im weg zerstören würde inklusive
des reiseziels denn das ist eine
konsequenz dieses antriebs er krümmt den
raum wie ein schwarzes loch und hätte
wohl mit seiner immensen gravitation
erheblichen einfluss auf seine umgebung
es gibt also noch ein paar kleine hürden
bis zum mob antrieb zu nehmen und jetzt
könnt ihr etwas gutes tun
den link zum buch gibt es nicht nur hier
unter oder auch hier sondern ihr könnt
den link auch in buchhandlung von finden
also dort das buch kaufen bitte
unterstützt in diesen schweren zeiten
die buchhandlungen und kaufen das buch
dort und hier geht es weiter mit einem
anderen video aus der edition zukunft
robert quantencomputer vor jahren noch
für unmöglich gehalten sind sie nämlich
realität geworden also staunen
draufklicken hier anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar klicks um santa
lucia mit der spektakulären edition
zukunft rowohlt bis dann bleibt dran